في تطورات الاحتجاجات في ايران افادت
تسجيل صوتي المسرب عقب اختراق وكاله انباء
فارس شبه الرسميه بان عددا من مسؤول
الاعلام الرسمي اعربوا عن قلقهم من ارهاق
قوات الامن على خلفيه قمع الاحتجاجات
واضراب التجار في اثنتين 22 محافظه
ايرانيه وفي اعتراف ايرانيا متاخر قال
امير علي زاد قائد القوات الجويه في الحرس
الثوري للمره الاولى ان اكثر من 300 شخص
قتلوا في التظاهرات حتى الان لكن بنسبه ما
فان منظمه نشطاء حقوق الانسان في ايران
قالت ان هذه الحصيله الرسميه تقل بكثير عن
الواقع وتقول هذه المنظمه ان اربع مئتين
وواحدا 51 محتاجا 60 من قوات الامن قتلوا
بالفعل منذ بدا هذه التربه كما اعتقل اكثر
من 18,000 شخص هذا هو اعلنت شرطه طهران عن
اعتقال خمسه اشخاص وصفتهم بعناصر مثيره
للشغب في حي نادي اباد شرق العاصمه